à l'étranger barack obama est rentré à
washington après son voyage de 24 heures
au ghana son premier séjour officiel en
en afrique celui ci a une nouvelle fois
multiplié les symboles près de six mois
après l'arrivée au pouvoir du nouveau
président des états unis une
caractéristique s'impose c'est sa
maîtrise de la communication
retour sur tout cela avec un chevron et
ron dimon ok rien états
si barack obama reprend au ghana son
fameux slogan ce qu'il sait qu'il fait
même s'il se fait accompagner de ses
filles lors de la visite d'une place
forte de l'esclavagisme
c'est qu'il sait que l'effet
sentimentale en sera renforcée
il faut s'y faire l'omni président
américain est aussi un homme ni
communicateur chauffe autant les
journalistes avec lui et son équipe la
communication devient à la fois un
huitième art et une science méticuleuse
tous les jours où quasiment un événement
est organisé qui permettra à barack
obama d'être dans le 20 heures
première règle être didactique le
président convoque régulièrement des
conférences de presse souvent prime time
au cours desquels il explique longuement
sa politique les journalistes continuent
à être sous le charme
deuxième règle
la segmentation au caire il s'adresse
aux musulmans le lendemain à buchenwald
accompagné d'elie wiesel a rescapé de
l'holocauste
il touche les juifs segmentation
thématiques aussi pour parler santé ou
relance économique
on va organiser des paroles ses réunions
avec questions réponses qui ont si bien
marché pendant la campagne ou encore
inédit une conversation avec les
américains par internet tout est blindé
mais on a juste sur michael jackson le
président envoie d'abord son porte
parole
mais devant l'ampleur de l'émotion
populaire il rien dire
je crois que michael jackson restera
dans l'histoire comme l'un des plus
grands hommes de spectacle car barack
obama est aussi un grand pragmatique
résultat six mois après son arrivée à la
maison blanche
61% des américains approuvent la
politique du président et 79% l'aiment
bien ça s'effrite un tout petit
mais ça en ferait rêver plus d'un là